[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the first key part of Barack Obama's
legacy is something his opponents can
never undo however hard they try and he
achieved it on his first day in office
he will always be America's first black
president I Barack Hussein Obama do
solemnly swear now execute
faithfully the president office of
President of the United States
faithfully perhaps we forget now quite
how historic it was a sign of how far
America had come despite all its racial
divisions and rancor so help you God so
help me God
congratulations mr. Prentiss for the
next eight years there are many
Americans who couldn't and still can't
come to terms with it
[Music]
I lost count of the number of times I
was told he was a dangerous Muslim
socialist who wasn't really American
when I was working there underlying all
that was a deep fear about what a black
president will do to America what it
said about what the country had become
problem in his country we know our
current president is one you know he's
not even in America we need the first
one of the biggest proponents of the
claim Barack Obama wasn't born in
America and therefore shouldn't have
been President was Donald Trump his rise
has undoubtedly benefited from those
sentiments this election was in some
ways a reaction to them the legacy of
being America's first african-american
president as it seems come with a price
[Music]
yes we can yes we can the second key
part of Barack Obama's legacy is also
something he can't have taken away from
him but hardly anyone talks about now he
and his team saved America and the world
from economic catastrophe it's one of
the unfair things about leadership no
one knows the size of the disasters
you've averted because they never
happened so you don't get the credit you
deserve for dodging them but people
forget that just two months before
Barack Obama walked into the White House
America suffered its most serious
economic crisis in decades and his
decisions were crucial and saving the
country from the consequences we've come
through a terrible crisis the American
people have paid a very high price
we simply cannot return to business as
usual
now as critics have pointed out that
also one is watched no one was punished
for the fraud and failings that led to
the banking crisis and not enough was
done to prevent something like it
happening a game but without a cool head
and the right team things would have
been far far worse
[Applause]
[Music]
the third Potter's legacy everyone knows
about everyone in America seems to have
an opinion about and unlike the first
two is at risk of being undone by his
enemies Obamacare
Barack Obama was determined to try and
fix America's health system but it used
up a huge amount of political capital
and it gave his fractious enemies of
course they could fight for and rally
around after that his presidency was
forever a battle to get anything done
Republicans were determined to make him
a one-term president and openly said so
and their tactics were cynical to the
extreme they blocked Obama's proposals
wherever possible
he wasn't without fault famously aloof
he's never excelled at the personal side
of politics he seems to see charming
cajoling or arm twisting his opponents
somehow beneath it as he said he wasn't
cut out to deal with the divided
politics at his time it's one of the few
regrets of my presidency but the rancor
and suspicion between the parties has
gotten worse instead of better I have no
doubt a president with the gifts of
Lincoln or Roosevelt might have better
bridged the divide and I guarantee I'll
keep trying to be better there are
plenty of things Barack Obama can be
criticized for he didn't close
Guantanamo killed many without trial or
to process with drones didn't do enough
to help black civil rights failed to
tackle the terrifying spate of mass
shootings on his watch historians will
argue over his foreign policy failings
for years to come too weak or too strong
in Israel responsible for the failings
of the Arab Spring asleep at the wheel
on Syria a statesman on Iran's nuclear
deal or guilty of a reckless gamble but
there's no doubt he agonized over the
choices he had to make and that's a clue
to another less obvious site for bombers
legacy one that donald trump may
unwittingly enhance the harder he tries
to diminish his record
Obama brought a dignity a sense of class
and decency and a complete lack of
scandal to the office of President no
drama
Obama infuriated his supporters as much
as his opponents he was condemned by
both for what seemed like a professorial
detachment but no one would question how
seriously and diligently he took his job
how much he revered his office and how
respected he leaves it all that may end
up counting just as much as anything
else when historians come to pass
judgment on Barack Obama's legacy in the
years to come